the jurgen experience
but again i'm a responsible grown-up
right i'm 54 years old and i know what
i'm doing um so when we think about
something like cocaine cocaine
not the [ __ ] that people sell on the
street that's been stepped on so like
when you go to places like columbia and
you go to the source and you get really
good cocaine
like columbia cocaine is about seven
dollars a gram whereas in new york it
could be anywhere from 60 to 100 a gram
um
and not as good as a product in columbia
so you go to the resource countries and
you get good stuff
um
it could be a really good evening with
you and your significant other you know
and um
um
all of these sort of stories of people
being paranoid
about the cops with cocaine there are
reasons to be paranoid if you're doing
something wrong
there so i get that i mean so i'm also
worried about being arrested that's what
i'm talking about yeah that's what's
exactly what i'm that's exactly what i
mean so there's a reason to that's a
rational sort of thing
uh but what's irrational is that are
arresting people for what they put in
their bodies yes agreed yeah agreed
wholeheartedly i mean i always point out
that you can go to cvs and buy enough
liquor to kill yourself absolutely 24 7
all day long absolutely it's so easy to
do absolutely yeah so but when we think
about cocaine and why it's illegal
cocaine came to the united states
in a pot for the popular masses in the
late 1800s
and coca-cola this guy john pendleton i
think his name was he put it in
coca-cola well this product a cocoa wine
uh and he was out of atlanta
and
uh he put it in cocoa wine in
1894
the next year atlanta banned alcohol so
before prohibition
alcohol was banned in orlando for
prohibition just atlanta just atlanta i
mean cities interesting various cities
banned this
prohibition happened in 1920
nationwide
so since they banned
alcohol in atlanta he had to come up
with a new formulation
and he and so what he did was tuck the
alcohol out added carbonated water and
sugar then you have coca-cola what that
that's this is how coca-cola this is how
coca-cola was
made and he put it in the soda fountains
so they sell that pharmacies at the soda
fountains and they were for whites only
so cocaine was used was typically
available only to white people at that
time but then in
i guess maybe
1899 early 1900s coca-cola began
bottling the products now it's available
to black people
and now you start to get these
the connection between violence and
cocaine use among black people
and
this sort of
narrative grew and grew
um to the point where we banned cocaine
effectively in 1914 largely because of
his association with black people using
the drug a similar thing happened with
opium and the chinese that's the real
reason
that those drugs are banned not because
of pharmacology you know what i'm saying
yeah now that's not to say that people
can't get in trouble with these drugs
because people do you know just like
they can get in trouble with alcohol
that's right that's right but the only
stories that we tell about cocaine
is the one where people get in trouble
yes but i gotta tell you
uh recently i watched uh
pete davidson's movie what was that
the king of staten island i think it is
it was
the first time in a popular movie where
um
the a hero
uh used cocaine and he was still a hero
so you might remember the scene where
steve buscemi and uh i think bill bird
they were talking about they didn't see
the movie oh it was a great start was
great a great scene where they were
talking about
pete's dad and pete's dad
had used cocaine previously
and
pete didn't know this
and
but it was just a matter of fact the guy
used cocaine he liked his cocaine
but he was still the good guy he was a
fireman he was a hero he was all of
these things and they didn't besmirch
him for using cocaine it's one of the
few times that you see in popular
culture that somebody uses something
like cocaine
and they're not besmirch they don't have
they don't go down this path of becoming
an addict and losing all of their
possessions because of the drug yeah and
so i thought like
they're doing something here that's
different and then that was really that
was a great scene yeah most of the
stereotypes about cocaine in hollywood
are you know people using people
seedy people people that have no
compassion for each other ruthlessly
ambitious people doing coke and just all
full of themselves and high on
themselves and i'm gonna take over this
[ __ ] town
that's what you you hear and see
you know yeah um
yeah i hope that changes man i know yeah
well i mean uh i i would try it with you
yeah i would try it yeah all right
especially listening to you and knowing
you probably get the real [ __ ] yeah i
just uh i avoid things that make me
confident i'm not interested in that i'm
confident enough i'm plenty confident i
like things that scare me that's why i
like marijuana so much i do i do people
think i'm kidding i'm not i i like the
paranoia i like freaking out because i
always come out of it at the other end
with some sort of a lesson because i
think sometimes um
we can shield ourselves from things that
are we're really worried about or shield
ourselves from concerns that we have or
even from
ruthlessly introspective thoughts that
come with uh high doses of marijuana and
that's the thing that freaks a lot of
people out i find them very beneficial
some of the best moments i've had
personally
are after some of the wildest trips
where i was like boy this is rough and
it but at the end when it's over i come
out feeling so much better i i feel you
i mean that's great i mean because you
know um
that's useful uh you feel like you're a
better person that's cool but sometimes
you just want to
be euphoric and just enjoy your
significant other sure i mean you know
what i'm saying so and and so cocaine or
some other drug
might be useful for that and so it's not
like you have to have only that
experience that frightens you and then
you become a better person that yeah at
the end of it
um i'm all for that that's fine you got
that um
um but i would just say
broaden your repertoire that's it the
problem is like yeah
if it was legal it'd be great like you
could get pure cocaine and you knew what
you were getting but if you're getting
cocaine in austin texas you're probably
getting it from some sketchy dude yeah
who is also selling a bunch of other
[ __ ] and yeah i mean i'm imagining i've
never tried to buy it yeah but you know
um
two things here
um
we got the technology to
put on the streets where people can
just submit small samples of their drug
10 milligrams which is nothing
and then they get a chem they get a
readout of the chemical composition of
their drug right we have that technology
if the public would put pressure on
their officials to make sure that it's
available to people where they can
submit their drugs small samples of
their drugs free and anonymously
uh and then they get this readout the
problem is it's so taboo
like if you even admit that you do
cocaine people are like look at this guy
who's ready to ruin his [ __ ] life
barely hanging on over there carl look
at you doing cocaine this is why in the
book i admit my heroine use my cocaine
use all of my drug use so
i'm trying to change that image because
i have met
people all around the world
some politicians and so forth and got
high with these people
of course i won't say who they are
but
the vast majority of people who use
these drugs
are people who are responsible take care
of their families they care about their
communities they do all this sort of
stuff but
hollywood and the media and the
mythology is so powerful in
showing only this one image yes um and
i'm trying to really disrupt that
because it's it's so harmful to so many
people
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between video and audio experience on
spotify you can listen to the jre in the
background while using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost all for free
spotify is absolutely free you don't
have to have a premium account to watch
new jre episodes you just need to search
for the jre on your spotify app go to
spotify now to get this full episode of
the joe rogan experience